and
what I'll just I'll just be back in a
minute yeah all right yeah I think yeah
and we'll give another minute for
everybody to join so if you're joining
please let us know where you're from
hold on a second here let me
upload
all right
so I had to recreate my configuration
foreign
uh one moment
and hold on just a second we'll be
starting in a minute
don't know why I'm having such
difficulty this morning
foreign
[Music]
yeah right back
just waiting for a file to open here
laughs
okay to stop
thank you
all right and thank you so much for your
patience everyone I want to take a quick
look in the chat and see where everybody
has told us we're from
and
two
[Music]
if somebody from New Jersey most
everybody else is from around India
Mumbai
oh wonderful
um and welcome good evening for those of
you who are in India good morning for
those of you in North America
and my name is Stuart Creek I'm with
simply learn I'm here with a doctor for
shatama assadani who is uh one of our
senior instructors and I'll let him
introduce himself in a minute but first
I want to
um
tell you a little bit about the program
we're doing today we're going to talk
about becoming a cloud computing expert
through the
postgraduate program from
Celtic
and we'll be asking a couple of
questions about you
will be telling you about cloud
computing careers we'll talk about how
how tech center for technology and
management education can help you
um we'll go over some learner outcomes
from this program and we'll talk about
the enrollment steps including a bonus
that you get for uh attending this
evening so thank you for being here
I want to let you know about that toward
the end of this session and we'll take
your questions as well
so
um first off how much experience do you
have
currently studying
are you and I'm going to put this into
the hole here
are you currently studying do you have
just a few years of experience or are
you seasoned professional at this point
put your answers into the poll question
and I'll close this in five four three
two one in the poll
well it's about half and half about half
of our audience or folks who are still
studying and natural for audience are
people who are in The Working World
welcome everyone
before
want to tell you a little bit about
simply learn we are the number one line
of line boot camp in the world we've
trained over 5 million professionals on
150 companies and we specialize in
digital skills so we help people prepare
and move ahead in the digital economy
few of our awards are there and
we'd love to have you join us in the
simply learned Learning Community
especially with Caltech
and
I want to mention uh Dr assadani I'll
let you push it on introduce yourself to
the audience yeah thank you through it
so hello and welcome everyone thanks to
it for giving the opportunity so I my
name is Dr purushdani and I'm assistant
professor in information technology
department in Sri ramdev Baba College of
engineering and management nagpur they
specialize in cloud computing Microsoft
Azure AWS and operating systems I'm a
Google Scholar corporate trainer
Microsoft certified trainer AWS
certified trainer three times certified
on AWS that is AWS certified architect
professional architect associate and AWS
certified practitioner I'm a Microsoft
Azure certified administrator as well
Oracle certified associate
and associated with Caltech University
for delivering their postgraduate
program into cloud computing and with
many iits IIT kanpur IIT kharagpur for
delivering their Masters program in
cloud computing yeah they have delivered
multiple corporate trainings with
multiple mncs in and outside of India so
this is and I have done my PhD in cloud
computing in resource scheduling in
cloud from vit velor so this is in short
about me yeah thank you thank you thank
you so much
um so
uh you're well positioned to discuss
careers in cloud computing because
you've had a long one and
um
so one of the things we say is that
Cloud's the backbone of the digital
economy is that I have a fair
description
absolutely
uh because
um cloud is the backbone of digital
economy because see uh it's like uh
almost uh 90 of the companies will move
towards cloud like by 2025 they say and
uh not just the startups even the
well-established companies are into
cloud or are moving into cloud
essential
um it is the backbone of digital economy
because
um use uh even save a lot of uh money
when you are into cloud and that said
that adds a lot yeah yeah and you know I
of course came up in the
days of uh initially Mainframe Computing
then mini computers
outset of the personal computer
Revolution many years ago
um and even not that long ago you know
we were all operating our own web
servers
um and we had to deal with things like
you know what happens when the load
demand
just skyrockets on a particular day or
after a particular event and how do you
deal with that
um and then cloud computing came along
and suddenly
it didn't have to operate your own
infrastructure you had the ability to
um do things like load balancing and
bringing on more resources in the
automatic way so
it says commoditized the
sharing the Computing resources
the distribution of information
in a way that
you know people didn't really
anticipate
30 or 40 years ago but today it's
uh
Central to the operation of as you said
almost any Enterprise and government
organizations and any size company that
can Leverage The Cloud
and not have to invest in a data center
of its own
so the definition the growth is
incredible isn't it absolutely the
growth is incredible and as you rightly
said that
um think about the growing uh business
so when when the businesses
um are growing in this feature uh so
they can just concentrate on their Core
Business like um let's say they take the
example of Netflix so Netflix is hosted
on AWS correct so Netflix is just taking
care of its Core Business solve that is
the entertainment business and rest the
infrastructure is managed by the cloud
provider so because the infrastructure
is managed by the provider they can
fully concentrate on their Core Business
similarly uh like take the example of
Amazon flipkarts during like in India
during their sale days
um the traffic on them is huge so at
that time more machines are added and uh
so horizontal Auto scaling happens and
that happens in an automated fashion and
and and and this is very easy this is
very much possible with the help of
Advent of cloud computing in nature you
don't have to maintain physical data
centers you don't have to manage them so
that's the beauty of cloud plus you can
create your machines in in matter of
minutes isn't it yeah I mean that's one
of the clever things that Amazon does
because there's such a huge web provider
and in order to make sure that they have
resources for their own e-commerce they
declare Prime days so that they can
create Peak demand all for themselves on
days where they know that their
resources are all dedicated to
themselves so it's a it's an interesting
world we live in and you know one of the
things is that you can pick you know all
your folks in the audience can pick
different places in this world to become
practitioners of uh this type of
technology so you can
choose to be
um
Cloud engineer Cloud developer that sort
of the basic level but then
got a lot of different paths you can
take what what are some of these career
paths uh
yeah so a great career paths actually
um the cloud is an ocean so if somebody
is thinking that maybe if I am an
architect uh only then cloud is meant
for me or if I'm a developer is cloud
meant for me so cloud has space for
everybody and anybody
um if you are a developer uh well you
can go to cloud and you can become a
cloud developer and then you have a lot
of services available there which which
helps you to make your development task
pretty easier okay so it supports almost
all the languages also and then of
course uh if you are an Enterprise
architect or otherwise if you want to
become an architect so again you have a
role of cloud architect which is the
which is him in boom
um in thing right now correct so you can
be there and initially you can start as
a cloud engineer
and if you are in database site cloud
has an offering for not just relational
databases but it supports your uh
non-sql databases relational databases
graph databases there's a support for
all different kinds of DBS all different
kinds of databases so uh I mean because
gone are the days when it was only the
relational database that used that was
good enough uh now you are in need of
different types of data nosql data like
when you operate with Facebook you have
graph DBS working in okay so cloud has a
support for all these like Amazon has
Amazon Neptune for craft DBS uh then you
have
dynamodb for nosql DB RDS for relational
databases correct so
um if you are a database administrator
or if you want to become a database
administrator well you can uh very well
be in a good place uh to be a cloud Devi
Cloud database administrator then again
Cloud security engineer so uh a lot of
like like when you talk about Cloud uh
people are very very about uh the
security part especially in the public
Cloud platforms but let me tell you uh
public Cloud platforms like AWS Azure
Microsoft Azure Amazon CWS they have
they are the market leaders in the world
okay and they have got a lot of security
measures to keep your data very secured
so they have a lot of mechanism of
keeping the data secured so there is a
lot for the cloud security engineer in
this field and yes um you can be in this
place then of course if you are a devops
guy
um because devops is the in thing uh
Gone are the days of waterfall model
when you used to build the complete
project and you show it to your
um client and then client would uh tell
you to modify the entire thing now uh is
the age of Agile development where you
develop your products in project in
parts and show it to the client and when
client approves you develop the other
part and then combine it to the previous
right so every time you have to do uh
deployment testing uh and
so this this this process has to be done
for every small module so then for that
you can just automate this process you
don't need any manual testers or you
don't need to deploy it manually every
time you can do it in an automated
fashion with the help of uh creating a
continuous integration continuous
development pipeline deployment Pipeline
with the help of devops tools in Cloud
as well so it supports all those tools
as well yeah so there's a lot of
different options for people
um the demand for people with these
skills is
incredibly
high and it's growing and the salaries
are keeping up so if you're a developer
the average salary in India is 10 lakh
if you're a car architect the average
salary is 20 luck and the upper limits
uh are these Fair upper limits or have
you seen higher numbers
I see higher number than these actually
for architect I know my friends earning
like uh 45 likes per annum okay yeah so
oh yes if you are a senior if you are on
a senior architect level yeah so do you
have the ability to set yourself on a
career path where if you continue to
gain experience and uh tend to upskill
you have a very very high uh salary
trajectory that you can look at so
that's that's a wonderful aspect of the
of the sector
um but to do that you have to have a
skill set that supports that right
of course yes otherwise how can you do
it yeah so so you can tell us about some
of these different aspects and how they
work together and and why it's important
to have like kind of a broad range
yeah correct so you need to be up to
date skills to be a cloud practitioner
of course see cloud provider selection
so uh when you have to Ops cloud like
when organizations go towards Cloud so
uh which Cloud platform they should
choose correct so uh when it comes to
public Cloud platforms
um they normally are into the uh like
the market leaders AWS Azure they are
the first choices and at times it
doesn't happen like they just go with
AWS or just Microsoft Azure this they
choose some services from
um Azure some services from AWS like AWS
is the market leader as per the Gartner
that is the research organization AWS is
the market leader in the um in the IIs
magic quadrant and Azure is the market
leader in the past quadrant platform as
a Services quadrant so there are
companies uh use some resources from uh
some cloud provider the other from other
cloud provider so uh today is the era of
multi-cloud actually
and so uh when it comes to multi-cloud
uh these Market leaders like AWS Azure
sometimes DCP they are the first choices
of any organization correct
um so yeah they so they they think of so
when they select the uh provider so they
think of various factors the security
aspect the availability aspect how much
their data would be available what are
the measures the provider is taking for
making their data available and of
course the
um costing part of it as well uh yeah so
the more the like AWS are assured the
more the bigger the cloud providers uh
the the more the profit they share with
their customers and that's why they can
offer the services for um for for very
competitive prices then uh their
competitors okay so um yeah these all
factors would be considered uh while uh
the cloud provider is selected for any
organization then application migration
so
now of course if if a company is in
on-premises and wants to move towards
Cloud so they will have to do different
kinds of migration they will have to do
server migration database migration
application migration okay and then how
you can do it so there are a lot of
services uh there are methods available
um in in all the cloud providers like
you have Azure migrate in Microsoft
Azure for seamless migration of apps DBS
and and and servers into Azure plus you
can go with the DMS database migration
service in AWS and application migration
and server migration you can do it there
as well then uh regarding performance
testing so of course um
there are a lot of tools services
available for doing the testing also
okay and it can be automated as well so
um that again is there for the cloud
workloads and with identity and access
management
um
uh this identity and access management
uh is uh nothing but uh there a service
to create different users in the cloud
I'll just quote a simple example let's
say uh there's an organized like like
right now I'm in Hyderabad giving the
training in TCS for AWS so I could see
my participants today the Learners uh
for there the TCS company has created
different accounts okay
um so they are having a root account and
then for the learning purpose for the
for their for their uh employees they
have created different IAM accounts IM
user accounts so that is the role of an
administrator and then they use the
services of the cloud let's say AWS and
then the um AWS will charge the company
root account on that so they can you can
create user accounts you can grant them
permissions like on the network
administrator will just have access to
networking resources the database
database resources like that you can
provide the permissions to those users
and yes that is all possible with the
help of identity and access management
then Auto scaling has rightly said
Amazon Prime days uh great Indian sale
big billion days during that time the
auto scaling is the feature for for
horizontally increasing the number of
VMS when the load increases so that the
website uh performance doesn't
deteriorate or the website doesn't goes
down so let's say if there are 100
servers running and the load on them CPU
utilization of those hundred servers
goes above 80 90 then more number of
servers are added to cope up to that
additional load so of course
and this way the website performance is
always maintained correct and when the
when the when the when the sale days are
over when the load is reduced on the
website so these uh additional uh what
you call it as servers they would be
automatically terminated as well so
downscaling also happens automatically
so that you are not charged for those
additional servers when they are not in
use okay so that is there plus apart
from there uh that there can be Disaster
Recovery Services so you can actually uh
like in Disaster Recovery uh you can
actually copy your data or your servers
in another region also okay so let's say
uh if you if a is your primary region
you can copy the data or services in B
region also so that tomorrow God forbid
if there is a natural Calamity and then
the entire region goes down then also
you can have access to your data all the
servers from another region so that's
the beauty of the cloud that's why they
say that people may die but the data
won't die Okay so that is so you have
good services like you have Recovery
Services vault in Azure to take care of
that thing Plus in AWS also you have
cross region application services
available that can take care of that
thing
then you have that services in API of
course in Cloud you can create your web
servers and then you can you have DNS
service to assign the names to them and
then you can use the application
programming interface to access them
then of course Cloud migration and
deployment so as I said you can do the
database migration uh server migration
application migration of your
on-premises services of your on-premises
servers
um into the cloud
correct and and and and and you have a
lot of mechanisms like before migration
uh you can do the discovery of those
on-premises Services you can assist them
and once they are ready you can migrate
them into the cloud
s
that's what you can do so it's a plan
cross assist it's not like uh database
management
as I told you
uh you can do the management of the
databases
um
the unreleased
databases and as I told you before only
into multiple clubs we are using
Services of multiple class
program also we are not just teaching
One Cloud platform
the last pressure time I think is a
network is uh a little bit uh yeah I was
I'm sorry yeah no worries but yeah so we
basically have just disconnect him no
ways that that happens to me yeah fairly
frequently sometimes
um but thank you um actually yeah
yeah I just finished so
[Music]
you might want to cut off your uh video
just just Audio Only first like it
is your gcp family video not visible is
it visible now uh your video is visible
but you might want to turn it off so
that your bandwidth is better for The
Voice
uh
[Music]
actually deploy multiple clouds I mean
and that's why we are teaching uh like
in our program we are teaching uh not
just one Cloud platform but we are
teaching multiple Cloud platforms like
we Market Lee platforms AWS Azure and
gcp and of course you have storage
so this is they have these Q8 services
thank you
all right and I'm going to move on to
the next uh topic here
so let's ask a question of our audience
you're all here because you're
interested in uh careers in cloud
computing and we assume that you've
looked at the different
we've assumed you looked at different
programs
um what has stopped you from
taking a cloud computing
certification or training program up
till now what is it what is it that you
didn't find that you felt you needed
and you can answer more than one of
these answers
I'm going to leave this open for another
15 seconds
you get your answers in
I will close this in five
or
three
two one so hit the submit button
and here are the results and the main
concern that most of you have is
can you find a program that's fully
comprehensive it's going to cover all
the skills that
a first time discussed
will you find a program that gives you
practical exposure examples that show
demonstrate your new skills
program that isn't just watching videos
add a program that fits your schedule so
you share those results with you this is
what you said
we'll move on to
a recap here
you can see that the ideal kind of a
program for this type of Skilling is
something that's comprehensive where the
the
learning path is aligned with the needs
of Industry
where the integrated labs and Hands-On
projects give you practical experience
for sure how important is that for
picking up these kinds of skills
see it is very very important I'll tell
you
um like like because I'm teaching with
simply learn here uh for I can tell you
that this is a very comprehensive
program and of course uh comprehensive
with industry aligned learning parts so
Hands-On lab experience project
experience is very much required because
there are two things when you are
learning cloud computing first is you
learn for the certification to gain the
certification of course that is also
very much required and the other aspect
is that you should be industry ready or
if you are into industry then you should
have that experience or or the real-time
experience so that you can work on the
projects you so that you can solve the
real-time problems and that comes in
with the Hands-On activities the
Hands-On Labs the scenario-based labs
the projects and that's why while we
teach like let's say if I teach so I
take up the real-time examples during my
class plus the Hands-On projects and the
scenario based left not just the labs
but the scenario based lab so that it is
like end to end real use cases real
real-time Labs uh are taken so that it
gives the real-time experience to my
audience and um they are prepared for
the uh real-time
um uh like uh the real-time uh Hands-On
uh in their uh offices on their projects
in the real life right and and you
mentioned audiences and that's an
important aspect of the program as well
because
um you know it's not like
when I was a kid we used to get kits
um some of them would mail to us uh on
the subscription some of them would pick
up at the store but it would be a
science fair project kit or that type of
thing it would have all the pieces you'd
need to do a Hands-On project and it
would have an instruction sheet
but
it it wouldn't have a person who could
guide you through and answer questions
if something was unclear in the
instructions whereas in this program you
know got the online
classroom where Persia time or one of
the other instructors is working with
you each week
and taking you through the examples so
that you don't have to figure out
um which parts go together and how to
fit them get a
Mentor who's showing you how that works
right and so that you know what's what's
a typical week in in the program you
prepare with
study materials then you have the class
and then you do your your labs and
projects that are independent before
next week's class
but can you come again please I was
going to say the psych the typical cycle
for a week in this Pro in this program
would be you do some of the independent
reading and watch the videos that
prepare you for the the week's topic
then you go to your live classes go
through the examples with you or the
other instructors and then
student does their own
um labs and
um projects after that to complete the
assignments right
are you able to hear me uh through it
actually for me I think
yeah it's it's just break a bit maybe
can you come again sorry
I I think instead of me reciting it
could you tell us what it's like
um just briefly why the the classroom is
so important
and how you prepare for that give me
give me give me um
give me one moment let me just connect
with another Net Connection will that be
okay yes yes certainly uh because I
think I'm not getting a connection here
can you just give me a minute
yes yes absolutely
yeah sorry for the technical
difficulties here it's this
is something that uh
we're all used to after the last several
years of working remotely so
it's also an illustration of why Cloud
engineering is important
we want our cloud services to be
reliable
yeah I think now it should be good
actually I am actually working from
hotel room so um the Wi-Fi here was not
good now I've connected my jiofi device
so now I think I'm good yeah all right
thanks so much
um yeah yeah
my question was you know the the way it
works with the virtual classrooms is you
you
um you do some pre-work
uh as a student as a learner you did
some pre-work during the week to prepare
for the class then you go through the
class exercises and then you do your um
independent labs and and projects
afterwards that is that pretty much the
cycle for each week
got it exactly so see what happens is
um it's like
when I'll give the demo of LMS maybe
I'll show this as well right you have
that you have the self learning videos
so from there you can prepare plus uh
the instructor can give you the prior
material uh that you can prepare before
coming to the class okay and then during
the class while the uh live class is
going on and the instructor is teaching
you the
um content so you are uh you are aware
about the basics of that content uh so
you can concentrate more and then you
can ask the questions and we follow the
practice of like I personally follow it
that uh no question should go unanswered
Okay so
yes uh so that way the questions are
taken and they are answered and uh then
of course
um you get those Hands-On lab on the
real-time labs and then uh after that uh
you can be given some assignment from
the instructor
um as and when required okay and so
that's how it goes yeah so yeah so the
huge the the very good advantage of live
learning class is that
um you get the real-time examples you
get the real-time experience plus the
instructor is there to solve your uh
real-time queries yeah then and there
itself right and the platform is
available 24x7 which means that yes you
have some scheduled classes and you can
pick the class schedule that fits your
uh your particular weekly uh Rhythm so
that you can pick weekend classes or
weeknight classes but the um
the rest of the work that you do can be
done anytime 24 7. so you can fit it
into whatever schedule and whatever time
you have available
and that's all wrapped up in this
postgraduate programming cloud computing
which designed and uh issued by Caltech
Center for technology and management
education and we at simply learned
deliver it through our platform
it's an 11 month program
say you should be able to devote 10 to
15 hours a week over that 11 months
to
um to this program so it's not trivial
it's but it is something that you can
schedule into the lifestyle of a working
professional
um it meets all the requirements that
the industry aligned learning path and
the Hands-On environment
a live virtual classrooms and at the end
of the process
you received your certification from
Caltech
so they monitor our program they oversee
us and make sure that we're delivering
it to their specifications so that they
can put their name on that certificate
um you have more than 40 Projects that
you've done along the way over that 11
month period including a Capstone which
we'll talk about
you also receive 30 continuing education
units up to 30 from Caltech if you are
in a field where you need to show your
employer or a licensing body that you're
taking continuing education
CEUs are the standard measurement of
being your education work that
[Music]
um
these bodies and employers accept
you get membership in the online Celtic
Circle which is a virtual
Alumni Association for people who've
taken Caltech ctme programs and you can
Network that with them over your
lifetime and go to their programs that
Caltech puts on for that group
um you'll have an online convocation
where you can have your friends and
family watch you get recognized by name
for completing the program and simply
learn provides job assist for people
um complete the program
and we'll talk about that in a few
minutes as well so
I want to mention Caltech and
hope that everybody's heard of Caltech
but Caltech is the California Institute
of Technology
it is not part of the University of
California system it is not part of the
California State University system it's
an independent private it's institution
been around for over 130 years and
it specializes in Graduate Studies
research so this is where a number of
people did their research to win the
Nobel Prize
this is where a number of people who've
won the Nobel Prize have come to
continue the research so this is a
extremely prestigious institution and it
is also one of the highest
concentrations of brilliant people in
the world
and
um it is home to a number of different
research Labs including the jet
propulsion laboratory of NASA where at
Caltech they build space probes and
their satellites that are launched into
space to do scientific research so it's
really an amazing place it consistently
ranks in the top five universities
worldwide and
uh
it the ctme was designed to take all of
this impressive knowledge and all these
skills and translate them into a form
that people can use in Industries
companies were coming to Caltech and
saying we want our people to be able to
do some of the things that we've learned
some of the skills that you have
they formed Caltech Center for
technology management education to do
that to provide the programs and uh
we're very proud to Simply learned to
help them deliver
several of their important digital
programs
so
eligibility and prerequisites
um
personal time you don't have to have a
programming background in order to
succeed in this program is that correct
uh heal so programming background is not
essential okay uh because
um
yeah because you learn the basics of
cloud first then uh uh you you learn so
in basics of cloud you don't need
programming language a programming
knowledge and then uh in the architect
level again programming knowledge is not
required that much correct and then
apart from that um
in in developer associate yes uh maybe
the programming knowledge is is somewhat
is required correct for AWS developer or
Azure developer associate but that is an
elective anyways uh but the uh
compulsory courses that you have for
that programming language is not a
necessary requirement so you may be from
a non-programming background but but
still you can opt for this program okay
uh yeah so when you pick you'll pick up
the skills that you need in order to be
able to succeed in the program during
the program itself so we designed it so
that it as you build up your skills
um you build up the ability to succeed
and success a part of the program but
you do have to come in with a bachelor's
degree this is as established a
requirement from Caltech and so you
either have to have your bachelor's
degree or you have to have uh the award
of your bachelor's degree scheduled for
some time during the 11-month program so
that by the time you finish the program
you need to have your bachelor's degree
in hand so that's a requirement
um you do not have to come in with work
experience you can come straight out of
school if you don't have work experience
um but work experience always helps so
you can understand the context of how to
use these Cloud skills
working environment
um so we're going to talk about how this
program prepares you and before Persian
time shows how the learning management
system actually works
um and we just go through what the
modules are and you'll be able to then
show how they fit into the learning
management system
yes Sean so basically see
um
so about these modules correct yeah
because the first ones the first one's
just the online orientation that helps
people understand how to use the system
and what the what classes they'll be
taking and where to find them and so
forth but once you've completed that
then you move into AWS Solutions
architect so correct correct I'll go
through it yeah please yeah so see in
the orientation sessions or cloud
computing program uh you get the
orientation session and I think the
orientation session is taken by um The
Faculty from uh Caltech itself correct
so they they take this orientation
session uh from Caltech University a
faculty takes this orientation session
of yours for cloud computing program
then uh you go into and these are the uh
compulsory subjects that you have to
clear that is AWS Solutions architect
associate you learn this
um so in this you learn about the basics
of AWS plus the architect level
knowledge of AWS so you get prepared for
AWS Solutions architect um course here
and in this course uh you talk about the
security aspect the storage the
databases the uh IAM identity and access
management users aspect
um the core Services the application
services like SNS sqs SCS and apart from
that some Advanced Services so that
consists of your AWS Solutions architect
program okay networking service and so
on uh right uh the the DNS service so
they form the AWS Solutions architect
um
of course uh then you move and then you
uh start setting aw Microsoft certified
Azure administrator that is ez104 the
code is so as I said uh we take up
multiple clouds so that you are prepared
so because today is the era of
multi-cloud platform so uh once you have
studied AWS yeah and then you studied my
then when you study Microsoft Azure so
normally the instructor tells you the uh
comparison also so okay if if let's say
for creating virtual machines in AWS you
have ec2 service so in Azure you have
um a VM service in Azure and plus other
comparisons as well okay
so that is there uh so in Microsoft
certified Azure administrator that is
ez104 you learn about different services
that an administrator needs uh that is
uh or even in architect needs um that is
about the storage the um uh the the
networks the compute uh and so on uh
right so there are a lot of services
um that you study in this plus about the
recovery services Vault uh the the site
recovery services okay so they are a
part of uh Microsoft certified Azure
administrator and then you go and study
about
uh Azure infrastructure solutions that
is a
z1305 okay uh so this is like after
doing this you become the architect if
you clear the exam you become Azure
architect okay and um in this you study
uh from the architect perspective the
different services like storage
um the the databases the uh virtual
machines and so on uh there are several
Services out there uh the migration
service and so on okay and guys once you
clear all these like once you complete
all these courses uh so and you and you
submit the project assignments projects
plus assignment plus you maintain your
attendance so after that um for every uh
course you get a certificate from Simply
learn and then you have a cloud
computing Capstone project that will mix
or that will include the services from
AWS Azure both and that would be from
multi-clouds and based on that a project
is formed and you have instructor would
guide you and would Mentor you for that
project and then you have to do that
project and you you submit that and then
you get the uh kuwaited uh this thing uh
that is the uh Caltech certificate
um postgraduate program in cloud
computing from Caltech University
Caltech USA which is I think ranks uh
the second topmost in the world Okay so
that's it and of course apart from this
you have these electives so these
electives are not the compulsory
subjects
um so even if you don't take this uh you
still can get the Caltech certificate in
cloud computing from Caltech University
USA postgraduate program a certificate
but if you want to learn these electors
of course you should be learning so um
these are also available in the program
fees itself so you can go with these
program electives like you can go with
devops on cloud Google Cloud platform
architect training as well AWS data
migration sysops associate developer
associate Microsoft certified Azure
associate and uh Caltech cloud computing
academic master class as well correct so
these are the electives that you can
even opt for and guys in almost all of
these subjects uh except few electives
you have both these options like you can
go with
um the self learning videos that are the
videos from some instructor or already
pre-recorded videos plus there will be
live learning classes uh that uh of
course will help you in the real time
and you can get your doubts solved as
well so yeah that is how it goes and the
electives as you mentioned some are
included in the course fee so you don't
have to pay extra take any of these
electives take as many as you have time
for and have interest in and we
especially recommend the Caltech uh
academic master classes because you get
to hear from Caltech instructors about
new and emerging topics in Computing so
this is a really exciting option
um
as we go into the demo uh first time
we'll show you how
you access and use these different tools
in the um learning oops excuse me
but I just wanted to to mention this
because
there's all sorts of different tools
that you have to use in the proficient
with and on all the different platforms
you use
and so it's really important to have
that hands-on experience and know that
for a particular uh problem or Challenge
and which tools to use and how to use
them so that's really an important
aspect of the course isn't it
okay yeah so let's say if you want to
store your object-based data let's say
your flat files uh images audios videos
text Data you want to do it in AWS okay
so which service you can go for uh you
can use the S3 service that is simple
storage service in AWS okay then uh if
you have log base data uh you want to
install operating system or some
softwares on your storage uh the
operating system files are the some
software so you can go with block based
storage like EBS elastic block storage
in AWS plus you have some
shared file storage like you want to
share a storage among your different
machines among your different ec2
instances among your different VMS so
you can make use of file share storage
like EFS or FSX storage elastic file
storage
um in in AWS Plus in Azure you can go
with Azure file for that purpose
um Blog blog for blog for object-based
data okay uh and Page block for Block
based data so that is this uh plus if
you want to have some computations uh if
you want to do some computations and you
don't want to create a server you want
to just write a function and perform
some computations if you want to do
serverless Computing so you can go with
AWS Lambda service in AWS in a show you
can go with Azure functions Okay then if
you if you if you want to use the nosql
DB okay
um you have no SQL data like uh without
relations like Excel spreadsheet data so
you can go with nosql databases like
Amazon dynamodb naws Osmos DB in Azure
correct so that's what you can go with
yeah but and and and then if you want to
let's say um you want to uh create your
you want to do compute you want to
create your virtual machines in Cloud
the servers in cloud and you want to do
the computations there so you can go
with ec2 Service uh that is offered to
you in an infrastructure as a service
mode ec2 in AWS elastic compute cloud
and in Azure you have VMS in Azure to
take care of that
um correct so that's there uh plus you
have Azure resource manager yeah
yeah so all of these different tools are
are things that you learn how to use and
you learn how to use them by doing
exercises with them and then as uh
versus them described the end of the
course you do a Capstone project usually
three to four weeks right right
at the end of at the end of the project
so probably when as I said during this
11 months program when they'll be
finishing off with their compulsory
courses like uh the orientation program
the AWS certified architect associate
the Microsoft Azure administrator then
Microsoft Azure architect uh then at the
end they do this Capstone project okay
because
um uh the the skills of all those
courses would be required for for
completing this Capstone project uh
wherein this Capstone project uh will
mimic the real life business scenarios
for True experience that you can
Showcase in your portfolios in your
resume and that can really attract the
um employers okay uh yeah so there's a
few examples of the kinds of projects
that you'd be called on to do you could
choose from you know doing a simulated
video application
um Healthcare
uh you know Restaurant Hospitality or
e-commerce pick whichever the areas
interests you most and it's not like the
most interesting challenge to solve and
then uh solve that problem these are
examples of the kinds of projects that
that you'd be doing in the course so the
end of the process you'll be able to
point to this and this is how you solve
the program
the problem how you built the solution
and quite um
potential employers or your current
employer at this set of skills that you
have so that's a really fantastic thing
um
we provide a
support environment there's a simple
learning aspect of the program that
gives you the maximum chance of success
so we have a program manager who's
assigned to work with Caltech and make
sure that we're delivering to their
standard then when you join the program
you join on a particular date with a
number of other people and that becomes
your cohort so there's a success manager
assigned to that cohort to help you as a
group and as individuals
succeed and keep up with each other of
course your instructors Shepherd you
through each course and you can draw on
the help and experience of your peers in
the in the class uh the other members of
your cohort and of course the curriculum
and resources are designed uh to help
you to succeed and to get the support
you need so all of that acts as kind of
an environment or ecosystem
to help you do your best in the course
so at this point I'd like to ask
Patricia to go ahead and show us what
the learning management system itself
looks like
sure
I'll just share my screen
[Music]
uh yep kindly give me the excess
okay now I have issue I have it yeah
yeah
I have it okay let me just
just a second yeah it's visible to us
yeah okay here it goes I hope it's
visible yeah fine so as I've already
switched on the post graduate program in
cloud computing okay as you can see here
and as you can see in this program you
have first of all uh the prerequisites
tab okay uh Superior prerequisites
anyways uh has been talked about by
Stuart
um if you have uh some good knowledge on
I mean some basic knowledge on operating
systems and computer networks that is of
help otherwise without that also the
instructors would cover that then um
coming to the courses part uh you have
the orientation session as I told you
initially okay
um that is the first thing that you have
here that is orientation session in that
uh you will have a live class uh okay
Plus in that also you have the self
learning
um content here
okay so
um self-learning video would be there
already pre-recorded video uh correct so
that would be there and in the live
class of course uh you can attend the
live class uh from the Caltech Professor
here in uh the orientation program
correct and after this you will get a
certificate for this uh that is this
particular program if you attend that
class you will get that certificate okay
uh then uh this is the first thing uh
first uh thing when you when you uh join
in this program this is the first thing
that you'll have to take up then you
take up the first course that is on AWS
Solutions architect associate so if you
go inside this course again in this if
you can see there is the section of self
learning videos so they are the
pre-recorded videos from some instructor
uh okay that are already there you can
learn from it on the different topics of
AWS Solutions architect and then there
are live classes in live classes tab uh
what you will see is the lecture
recording uh of your live classes uh
that you can have it on maybe weekends
or uh that is on Saturday Sundays
morning evenings so you will see the
recordings of those live classes here um
in the live live classes section okay
then
um after this you have this assessment
part so in assessment part you can see
there are assignments uh that you can
solve okay and plus there are the
project so after every course like AWS
course after you do it you have a course
end project so you have multiple course
and projects and
um you can do one of them or you can do
all of them also but the mentor the
instructor will help you will Mentor you
on one of these projects or maybe more
than one of these projects but let me
tell you
you will have to
um uh for forgetting the certificate
here you will have a requirement that is
you will have to complete one of that
project plus one of the assignment that
is given that may be given to you one
test with 60 marks and you have to
complete one project out of these four
projects and in of course in which the
instructory mentor will help you out and
then you also have to complete
um either 85 percent of live learning
videos uh I repeat either 85 percent of
live learning videos or you need to
attend accent or more sessions of your
live learning classes correct so that is
what you need to do and if you achieve
this particular criteria then you will
be able to unlock your certificate for
AWS certified Solutions architect
associate from Simply learned okay and
um of course uh as far as the labs are
concerned now see when it comes to Cloud
AWS Azure so you need to have X is to
lab so do you really need to create your
personal accounts with your debit cards
so the answer is no so see this is one
of the advantage of of Simply learn
where in many uh other people may not
provide you this thing that but simply
learn provides you the practice Labs
okay so you have access to the sandbox
environment here you can just launch the
lab and you can start doing the labs
from uh these simple Elon labs and it
has a support for AWS Azure all these
Labs okay so you can just start that
total from this launch lab section and
you can start doing the lab and you you
don't have to create then your personal
lab or your personal account and you
will not be charged for that okay so
this is again there okay so uh this is
there and yeah so
these are the things uh for for for
every course that you will see here so
this is for AWS certified Solutions
architect associate and similarly so
this is the second program and then you
um once you complete this then you can
go for the third one that is Microsoft
Azure administrator is at 104 as already
said so in this ez104 Microsoft Azure
administrator associate uh you will
again have the self learning uh videos
as I told you by some instructor then uh
the live learning classes in which you
will see the recordings of your live
classes then of course the assessment
part of it wherein you can see the
assignments plus the projects plus there
is reference material section which I
forgot to tell you guys so you can see
the ebooks the projects the lab guide
the practices cheat sheet all out here
okay you can download it as well on your
system and you can download and use it
from your system correct so see this is
getting downloaded on my system
ebooks.sip okay plus the uh so apart
from this material the uh the instructor
is taking up some extra material he can
share it in uh with you
um also he will share it with you as
well correct and yes so here also for a
sure also you have the practice Labs
like for AWS so you don't need to create
an Azure account to do the labs uh you
don't need to create your personal
account you can start using it from
these uh simply learn Labs the Azure
labs and then of course in the
certificate section so you need to uh
the similar criteria kind of you need to
complete either 80 percent of or more
sessions of live learning class n85 or
85 percent of self learning videos
um and uh of course you have to complete
one project to get this Azure
administrator associate certification
from Simply learn and then you move to
the next course that is uh designing
Microsoft Azure infrastructure Solutions
AZ 305 and again the same criteria
follows here you have self learning
videos then you have the live classes
okay self learning videos consist of
pre-recorded sessions of some good
trainer then you have the live learning
video live live classes where you find
the lecture recordings of um
an instructor uh of your of your
instructor who takes your life classes
then you have the assessment section uh
of course in that again you have the
different projects and the assignments
uh you can opt for you have to complete
at least one project again here
um so instructor will help you out uh in
that uh we'll Mentor you in that and
then you have the reference materials
here also you can download it and use it
and here also you have the practice labs
and of course you'll be able to uh
unlock your certificate once you attend
80 or more sessions of your live classes
or 85 percent of self learning videos
plus you complete the project
um so that's there so after this course
once you complete this course then you
come up with what uh then you come up
with the cloud computing Capstone
project okay so In This Cloud Computing
Capstone project
um
okay so In This Crowd Computing Capstone
project uh if you go inside you will
find again the self learning video plus
the live class okay and that will
contain the lecture recording of the
mentoring session that uh an instructor
will take uh for you uh to complete this
particular project and that is the
Capstone project plus you will have the
assessment uh that you can
um uh go with so you have to complete
one of these Capstone project okay and
reference material it's there uh the
practice lab is there which helps you to
open the lab and then you can unlock
your certificate if you attend the 80 or
more sessions of that mentoring session
plus if you complete one project out of
it and of course in the labs you can you
see you have access to Azure Labs also
in AWS Labs also because this is the
Capstone project that can include Azure
Services also plus AWS Services also so
it will be a mix of both that you get a
real-time experience of how you can use
multi-clouds together okay so that would
be there and uh so this is so these are
the
um necessary things that you have to go
through and once you complete all of
this guys then you get the coveted PG
program certificate from Caltech
University uh okay and um yes so you get
that plus as said is rightly said by
Stuart that this program uh these are
the compulsory courses then there are
electives which are also available to
you in the uh same program fees you're
not charged extra for that and in that
you can go for electives you can go for
one or as many as you like and again in
all those electives you have the similar
things like self learning videos and the
live learning classes that are being
taken care of in some of the electives
you may find just self learning videos
but in others you will find the live
learning classes as well like here uh
for cpme cloud computing Master Class
you find the self learning plus live
videos okay live class uh then um
you have
um this Azure developer associate AWS
developer associate AWS this Ops
associate AWS database migration uh
Google Cloud platform architect devops
on AWS uh correct so all of these are
here and of course for every course that
you complete you will get a certificate
out of it as well okay for that
particular course as well uh that you
can have it correct so um again I for
getting the certificate you will have
the similar kind of criteria okay that
mentioned for the
um compulsory courses for electives as
well okay so uh that would be there and
that is how you go about it yeah can you
show us the community feature of the yes
yeah yeah sure uh so uh see this is the
program certificate so see once you are
done with the elective courses and if
you want if you can take the electives
you can do that but once you complete
the compulsory courses then you can
actually unlock or you can meet the uh
well if you meet that criteria you
complete the compulsory courses so
you'll be able to unlock your
postgraduate program in cloud computing
certificate from here uh from the calc
Tech University correct so that's there
and yes coming to the community feature
so
so uh if you if you if you go to this
community feature here so guys uh simply
learn has created a community here so
when you are in that course you can
actually interact with your peers with
your other Learners in that course
through this community plus the
instructor can communicate with you on
this community uh plus you can share
additional materials additional links
also on this community apart from the
standard content that you will have uh
plus if you have any doubts any any
difficulties uh during the week time
like during the live class you can ask
to the instructor plus plus during the
week time if you come across any
difficulty while you are practicing or
while you are reviewing the concept so
you can put it on this community and
then the team from Simply learn uh or
the instructor can answer to your
queries okay so or your peers can also
answer to your queries correct so you
can create a thread and then you can put
your queries onto this community as well
correct so you can interact and this is
a very good platform to interact with
your peers and get your doubts solved
and with simply learn team as well okay
so this is there and apart from this
um apart from this community uh see
um there is uh this uh I think the mild
sources section uh of course here you
can see uh the different uh webinars I
think you can see here Minecon and then
this on 29th June so you can have access
to that then this of course you can have
access and you can visit and uh you can
listen to these as well apart from this
um
uh uh so uh there is this help support
uh you can you can raise a ticket with
simply learn team and they'll be
available for you to answer your queries
um you can you can chat with them and
you can get your you can open the
tickets and they will get back to you
they will they will solve your issues
okay
um if at all if there are any okay and
yeah so that's there yeah I think I'm
not missing on anything now right no I
think that you ever do everything so
thank you for that yeah
I'm going to go ahead and go back to the
uh
presentation so I'll take back the
screen
yeah and I think the support is also
available for uh I think uh most of the
times correct
yeah support the help desk is 24x7 so
24x7 yeah
anytime that you are available uh you
have a question if you're working at
three o'clock in the morning on a
project
have a question or uh there's a glitch
then
you can access the help desk if
want to talk with your peers your
instructor and you put a question into
the forum
um they'll see it when they access the
community Forum um
so that may
take a little bit longer unless other
people are up at the same time as you at
three o'clock in the morning
thank you for this and I just wanted to
mention the um
the People Who oversee the program from
the Caltech side so Rick Hefner is
Caltech uh ctme executive director in
charge of all their programs
John wedge is a specific program
director with this program
and we report to them in terms of the
quality of the curriculum the quality of
the delivery of the curriculum
um they put as we said their name on the
certificate so they monitor and control
us very carefully in that aspect
talk a little bit about learner outcomes
so the people that you'll be learning
alongside in your program
um are people coming a lot of them will
be working professionals coming from
other backgrounds so
they'll come from companies like you see
here IBM or Laboratories or Barclays
Bank
um
people coming from Information
Technology and software certainly but
also from banking financial institutions
e-commerce industrial applications
Health Care pretty much every
sector of the
economy every industry sector because
cloud computing as we discussed earlier
is pervasive it
everywhere in every type of company and
organization
so you'll be
um
getting the opportunity to learn from
and network with experience from other
people
that's one of the great things about
this kind of program with the live
classes isn't it appreciative
is absolutely absolutely and that's the
beauty like you have people like cloud
is everywhere like you talk about any
industry because um see at the end of
the day infrastructure is required for
any market like any industry whether it
is a grocery store simple whether is it
is it is e-commerce company whether it
is any sort of company whether it is
software product information technology
any company needs the infrastructure and
when they need the infrastructure why
they would need it to maintain by
themselves if Cloud providers are there
to manage and maintain it for them and
they can concentrate on their business
only correct their Core Business uh so
yeah cloud computing prevails everywhere
okay so uh yeah that's the beauty and
that's why all these different companies
need people who act as that uh
point of interface between the cloud
providers are using and the business
that they're that the organization is
doing so that the
EOS the cloud professional provide that
connection between the resources on the
one side and the need on the other
that's really what drives it demand for
people in this industry
um you can go on our
website and I'll share that URL in a few
minutes but you can see a video of
ravine's uh
experience and testimonial about his
experience with this program and how it
helped him develop his Independent
consultancy Business
um that's very exciting you can see here
jumana on the right uh faithful to come
back from a career break and get a 50
salary hike which is a pretty uh
excellent result
and Rajiv versus extremely
uh pleased because he also got a good
salary hike although he didn't tell us
what it was but
um we would love to be able to add you
to this
roster of people and you'll see a number
of other testimonials on our site as
well
in fact Rajiv was my learner only yeah
very good
um
some people have asked they mentioned
the job assist program uh job assist uh
if we learned career service for India
Learners uh we also make it available in
the United States I apologize if you're
joining from a different
a region or country because we don't
have that available there yet but we are
working on that but within India within
the US you get access to a premium job
board
different in each of those two countries
but it's similar services that get you
exclusive job listings and a discrete
discrete and confidential Place do your
job search so that you don't have to
expose it to your current employer you
also get really important Services
resume review and rewrite which allow
you to tailor your resume
to uh cast through the automated
tracking systems and AI Bots that first
screening resumes these days
um format your resume so that those
systems can access your skills your
experience and match them up to the job
description and then still maintain
your resume's attractiveness to the
human beings who will see it so that's a
really important
kind of art form and you get to work
with a writer who will take you through
a couple rounds of resume rewrite to get
you
in the best shape similarly the
one-on-one interview service because you
have to pass phone screens you have to
do technical interviews with people who
might be your new peers or your new
supervisor and then you have to also ask
the cultural fit interview
talks about you know whether you fit in
with the organization whether you're a
team player and that type of thing and
all of those require you to put a
different aspect of yourself front and
center in your interview so being able
to practice each of those types of
interviews with the real human being is
a valuable aspect of the service this is
not a job placement service this is a
career assist service so we we're not
guaranteeing that you will get placed uh
or we're not taking responsibility for
placing you but we are giving you the
tools that you put your best itself
forward
the job search and help you find
Opportunities so
this extends for six months after you
get your Celtic certificate so you've
completed the program over the 11 months
if you want to dip into these Services
during those 11 months you can do that
and then for an additional six months
you get to use these Services as much or
as little as you prefer
[Music]
um
at this point I want to ask a question
based on what you've heard so far just
on what you've heard so far
um are you interested
in enrolling in this partner
I'll leave this open for just about 15
seconds total
I'll close this in about five seconds
or
three
two one
[Music]
and three quarters of our audience are
interested so I'm going to share with
you
uh the steps that includes the cost
in Roman steps
first
um
email us at ask us at simplylearn.net
going to put into the chat that email
address just for your convenience
hold on a second
just the chat here
but once you email us we will uh verify
your educational credentials
making sure that you've got the
bachelor's degree will also look at any
other qualifications you want to share
with us including any work experience
you might have that you think is
relevant
um any other types of information once
we send you that admission letter you
can get enrolled
and
the next cohort
starts in just a few weeks with the
orientation session on 18 July and the
class is starting 22 July so we
recommend that you get in touch with us
right away because we limit these
cohorts to about 25 to 30 people in
order to make sure that
instructor can give sufficient attention
to all of the students
so if you're interested in getting
started with us July cohort please reach
out to us now and we'll get started
process if you have any other questions
please reach out to us
and
mentioned
the price of the course
um I'm giving you the price in India
this course is available in many other
countries as well and you can
see the pricing or ask us and ask us
simplywink.net for the local pricing
in India is one lock 59 000.
and
the financing
Emi basis is as low as 5411 a month low
interest rate and
um so
we hope that will fit into your budget
again we recommend that you hurry and we
do have
a bonus offer for you so when you
contact us at ask us at 79.net
you'll be given information on how to
claim a discount coupon for the July
cohort so if you're decided to join us
for the July classes
we're going to offer you a discount and
you'll learn about that from the
learning consultant that ask us at
simplylearn.net
um
so for those of you who said you're
interested and based on what you now
know
um how soon would you like to enroll are
you looking at the July cohort or would
you look at August September
or do you want to plan further down the
road
this open
for another 10 seconds
close this in five
four three
two
one
and a share the result
and
about 40 percent
a little more than a third of our
audience are interested in starting in
July or maybe August September
and for those of you looking further
down the road please do contact us and
ask us at simplywed.net because that
will let us keep in touch with you let
you learn about future
cohorts of the program and also answer
any of the questions you have and
uh we have questions about the discount
but that will be answered if you contact
us and ask us simplywed.net
let me move on we're going to do the
questions and answers
and
I am going to
stop the screen share so you can talk to
us rather than talking to
[Music]
um
the slide
all right
and let's start with the questions from
the question and answer as opposed to
the chat
um
so Newton has a question for your person
talking how is learning cloud computing
uh helpful for somebody who's uh data
science or machine learning
why is cloud a valuable addition to that
skill set
okay
Sean uh so see of course um a data
science engineer or machine learning
engineer
you have the services for these domains
also in cloud like a very popular
service in AWS AWS recognition Okay
um plus there are other services for
machine learning that supports the
machine learning Engineers so you get
the tools and Technologies out there
that will help the machine learning
engineer to do their job really easy in
the cloud platform correct
apart from that of course so that helps
the data science and the Machine
learning engineer so as I said uh see
cloud is an ocean okay so you have a
support for all the different types of
role whether you are into blockchain you
are into robotics you are into iot you
are into machine learning side you are
into AI artificial intelligence uh it
has got an answer for all it has got uh
services for all especially the market
leaders like AWS and Azure yeah so that
way it is really useful for you yeah and
one of the interesting aspects of you
know AI machine learning is
that the models need data uh and the
more data they get the more accurate and
the more valuable they become and so
understanding the cloud environment
where that data is going to come from
and how it's going to be collected from
sources that may be around the world in
this different locations different
Industries different environments that's
a really powerful addition to your skill
set for that I would like to add here
um there is like uh if you if you can
see Amazon Go technology uh that uh is
uh that was that was launched in Seattle
USA so that is built on machine learning
algorithms and the centrifusion and your
computer vision okay so how it basically
works like you can just tap and go in
any of the malls and then you can take
the products put it in your basket as
soon as you put it it would be added to
your cart and if you if you if you if
you think of removing some item from
your basket as soon as you remove it it
would be removed from your cart and then
at the end when you just go you don't
have to cue in the lines um you don't
have to wait you can just keep walking
and the you just tap on your phone and
you pay uh so that's the beauty I mean
uh that that that behind the scene they
are using those machine learning
algorithms to
um actually achieve that
yeah and that's a that's a great example
of how
what you uh developed in the machine
learning side that has to be deployed in
the real world so understanding how that
is
deployed out on the cloud to the
different stores that have Amazon Go
technology
users yeah in fact the video is
available on YouTube I have it in my
slide also if you wish I can show it as
well if required otherwise not yeah we
won't show it today but if people reach
out to you they can ask you for that
they can see it on YouTube Two Minutes
video
um
this recording will be shared yes we're
going to share this link to this
recording in a follow-up email but I'll
also have information about the discount
code
um
and
is there a better and you can have a
follow-up question is there recommended
or a better Cloud platform for machine
learning or is
the basically can you do it on any
platform
uh no it's it's not like you can do it
on any platform it depends on the
support that the cloud provider is
providing to you for that and let me
tell you AWS has got a great support
like if you'll ask me about the uh
monitoring services so
um I mean I would say better than ashore
the AWS has got better support for
monitoring Services they are having
better so so AWS has got very good
services like matured services for
machine learning even Assurance so not
every cloud provider you'll get those uh
support okay but these Market leaders
have it yep uh guard Kumar asks about uh
the whole list of tools and and you can
take a look on our website I will share
that URL with you just a couple minutes
um so you can go to the program page for
this on our website and see a fairly
comprehensive listing of the different
tools that are that are part of the
program but
um
you can also download the syllabus and
take a look there uh it's really
more than we can list on any one given
page or
document because of the number of
different
tools and we update the course regularly
to include new things as they come out
um
you see new tools coming out all the
time from both Amazon and from Azure oh
yeah
of course plus apart from that like I
had already mentioned also that some of
the core services and the application
and Advanced Services that you would be
learning in this particular courses uh
like the networking the storage the
compute the
databases the application Services
migrations
Recovery Services yeah those are all
going to be a part of plus additional
services are also there so as rightly
stated by fluid you can always see on
the page
attendee who asked about the language
requirement and our instruction is
delivered in English
um
so that we can reach the widest possible
audience
um are there any tools that people can
use to uh
get other local languages
or
when they rewatch a video or that type
of thing or is that not available yet
okay
um I don't think so that is available
yeah I apologize for that but for this
for our courses you do need to be uh you
have a basic Proficiency in English
um
compulsory subjects and cloud computing
I think we talked about that and we set
up a Core Curriculum that takes you a
through both AWS and uh Azure and gives
you a grounding in that prepares you for
their uh external um
certification tests and you can see in
the program when you re-watch this video
you'll see the electives again
um see that there are electives that
will prepare you for a number of the
other certifications they offer as well
how will this be helpful in the
pharmaceutical domain
um can you I have some ideas about that
but can you tell
what your feelings are about application
of cloud and pharmaceutical to me yes
correct okay uh so see in pharmaceutical
companies first of all
um you have to do a lot of r d research
and development okay so um for that r d
purpose uh let me tell you um Amazon or
Azure have got a specific virtual
machine instances like spot instances
which are offered at a very lower cost
okay if you'll compare them with on
demand or on-prem or or reserved
instances so these instances which are
offered at very lower cost
um can be used and they are normally
used because in that companies in r d
you you just need a lot of computations
and you're not worried whether the new
instances are coming in the older one
are going on because going out because
the the uh these instances can be
evicted preempted at any time also but
we are not worried about it you just
need a lot of computations at lower cost
for the r d purpose so there of course
40 instances VMS what we
AWS can be used plus apart from that see
uh for your pharmaceutical companies
also
you need the infrastructure you uh you
need uh those servers okay so of course
uh the Cloud can be used for that and
the pharmaceutical companies can
concentrate on their Core Business yeah
and I can give you an example from
personal experience where I was recently
in
a field test of the new vaccine for
respiratory syntactical virus RSV it's
just approved this last year so as part
of this the study I don't know whether I
got the real vaccine or the placebo but
I in report to you I didn't get any
head colds for the last couple of years
which was a pretty amazing thing for me
um but to do this study I had to report
weekly
through an app on my smartphone so you
have the the cloud environment resources
and applications that
allow the thousands of people who are
participants in the study to report
their experiences report weekly on
um whether they had any new symptoms
then if they did they have to report
what they are and set up appointments to
follow it up that all of that is an
example of how what used to require a
lot of manual paper based record keeping
can be done through a cloud-based app
delivered out
people's mobile devices so cloud is
changing each industry and
pharmaceuticals is no exception the ways
that we didn't
and
uh Perez Jane would like to see the
video if you could drop the link into
the chat uh for that
um if you happen to have that I don't
radically have it actually it is in my
presentation
what search term would people use to
find that in Google
sorry what if somebody wants to do a
YouTube search for that what the search
term Amazon go Amazon go uh technology
uh they can just search for super
otherwise I'm just searching anyways
nice experience good one to hear it from
you
yeah
financial aid also there's a course
about that Duke contact us and ask us
it's definitely learn.net they'll be
able to answer that question
um
I think that pretty much covers all of
our q a so I'm going to go ahead and
move on to a final question for you and
the audience
go ahead
yeah uh this is I'm pasting that link
Amazon
yeah just uh
brows it from the YouTube yeah here's
the link I've pasted it for all okay
perfect and
let me move past this
slide
so one last question if you would like
us to reach out to you proactively
um
let us know and we'll contact you
directly otherwise you can contact us
through either the web page or uh at ask
us at simplylearn.net I will put into
the chat
the
information about our web page as well
you're answering this question
to the chat it goes
all right so now in the chat you have
another copy of that email address but
you also have the URL for the program
page and also do check the link that
personal term just dropped for the
Amazon Go technology because it's
fantastic
and
I'll share the oh so those of you who
said yes we will be contacting you
um and
oops
if we just need to make this disappear
here
and you had a comment personal
yeah yeah I think there are some chats
in the chat window may I take that uh
yeah go right ahead uh there's one
between two things that I am a beginner
could you please tell me how I can start
with good knowledge so see uh I would
suggest you to have some basic knowledge
on operating systems and networks if
that you can have it um it would be good
uh for you to join this program if you
don't have it then also it would be
covered uh in these courses somewhere
here and plus when you join this
um you can ask for uh the Linux
self-learning videos also that the team
can supply to you and yeah you can get
yourself prepared on that uh non
non-technical background people can
enter The Cloud of course yes as I told
you you can always enter the cloud
platform in fact I know many people who
are from non-it background or from btech
in Mechanicals electricals or not even
btex uh joining the program and doing
really good in the program yeah yeah so
we did have somebody who mentioned a
mechanical background and
um
you know cloud computing for somebody in
a mechanical background you want to take
a look at what the needs are and whether
you want to stay in the mechanical uh
domain use your domain knowledge and add
your digital skills to that or whether
you want to Pivot into
becoming a
digital professional of some sort
um but if you're going to stay in
mechanical engineering you might look at
cloud computing you might look at data
science or Ai and machine learning as
areas to
um
apply within the mechanical domain so
you have a lot of different options and
again if you contact us we can our
learning consultant can actually go over
some of those with you so we want to
thank uh
pressure time for being so generous with
your time
and your knowledge today thank you very
much
yeah thank you through it uh there are
uh okay may I take this one or two more
sure go ahead
yeah I'm so sorry but uh yeah just one
or two more uh one is taking that it
admin on premises can I get a job on
cloud engineer yes of course you can in
fact you can apply for the role of cloud
administrator and yeah so minimum six
years experience is not required
actually for that you can still apply
for that
um okay so that is there yeah
all right
and thank you again and um the QR code
will take you to the URL that I shared
uh for your convenience
I want to thank everybody here who
joined us this evening or this morning
if you happen to be elsewhere in the
world
um
and we really appreciate you taking the
time we hope this
hopefully in
evaluating your decision to become a
cloud computing professional and we hope
to welcome you into the Learning
Community with simply learn and with
Caltech ctme
with that we conclude our webinar so
thank you again I would uh I would also
like to add fruit here maybe buddy but
uh not just any domain like even if you
want to be an entrepreneur even if you
want to start up your own startup a
startup company and if you are
restricted on your budgets if you don't
have the infrastructure uh well you can
start your company on cloud and in a
piece of room uh like you can start your
IIT firm on cloud and use the servers on
cloud and uh that way you can really
save on your capital expenditure because
there will be just operational
expenditure and for from that
perspective also you should learn these
skills uh how you can operate into cloud
and of course um if you are into
management role uh then also you should
learn these skills so guys um it's not
just for the it Engineers it's for other
players also this cloud computing
knowledge is really essential yeah
thank you thank you I was going to say
with that let's conclude our webinar and
uh again we hope to welcome you into our
learning community so